Comparing women to men
is like comparing almonds to cows.
Stay with me.
Calling it chest feeding is like calling it almond milk.
It's almond juice.
Juice from an almond?
Since when did nuts have nipples?
Oh yeah, you can milk anything with nipples.
They are confusing you as a consumer
and ill informed consumer
to consume juice from an almond
as if it is the same damn thing as the milk from a cow.
Because we all know they don't want us eating real food.
But what we don't realize is
us women are constantly being mine.
F by wordplay.
Feminism degrades the out of women.
If a man can just choose to be a woman,
choose to breastfeed a child,
if this he says their milk is just as viable as ours,
then what the hell are women good for? Y'all?
I just can't.
It's too late.
My brain is just blue.